[Musique]
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
c'est hier après-midi que j'ai pris la
nouvelle en pleine gueule chez
l'opticien
je n'avais pas de raison de me méfier de
cet homme
c'était un opticien moyen avec une tête
de petit chien moyen
c'est une de ces têtes d'une banalité
hors du commun une tête oubliable
au-delà du raisonnable
une tête outrageusement ordinaire et
pour tout dire plus courante que l'eau
du robinet
bref une tête d'une telle platitude que
l'année Tom qui la croise se demande si
c'est Isabelle Huppert ou Michel
d'Ornano
je ne doutais pas que c'est un
signifiant son blues elle est gâché ma
vie
j'étais entrées là sur une impulsion
pour m'acheter des lunettes noires
dessinées à cacher mon intrépide regarde
quand c'est ressurcitaires buriner
elle accorde en fiévré des Mille et Une
groupies inassouvi que la rue jette
pantelante à mes trousses quand Phébus
attardant ses rayons sur leur coup
juvénile pour d'impossible Ruth ou je ne
serai pas leur mail effet sans feu et la
fièvre nombril et pousse vers mon corps
alors quelconque les a pas
bonjour Docteur est-ce que vous avez des
lunettes
peut-être mon entrée en matière est-elle
heurter l'amour propre de ce plat
imbécile
à l'instar du vieux Prévert qui disait
tu es tout ce qu'il aimait je dis
docteur à tous les hommes en blanc j'ai
déjà remarqué que ça énervait les
boulangers
au lieu de vous emmerder l'après-midi
dans vos bureaux insipides à essayer de
vendre des moissonneuses batteuses
hydraulique par correspondance à des
ploues qu'il est très ou apprendre par
cœur la constitution de la 4e dans les
pots de sciences chiotte
sortez dans la rue sortez dans la rue
pomper le bonheur hydrocarbot
tchernobyllesque gorges-en vos poumons
fripés saturé de jus de Camel entrer
dans une boulangerie entre deux fournées
à l'heure où cet artisan emblème est
farineux s'exhume de son pétrin pour
venir expectorer ses calembours Rachid
Dex mitron sous le nez des ménagères
j'en ai subi un mois pendant 10 ans qui
ne savait pas vendre un bâtard sans
hennir et un enfant sans père pour la
petite dame
quelle dérision
bref quand votre tour arrive vous
regardez le boulanger au fond des yeux
et vous lui lancez gaiement bonjour
Docteur est-ce que vous avez du pain
il y a le mien la première fois c'est la
tellement troublé qui s'est mis à ranger
ses miches en serrant les baguettes au
lieu de faire le contraire
bonjour Docteur est-ce que vous avez des
lunettes
il lui des lunettes de quoi des lunettes
pour les yeux
quel genre marron des lunettes pour les
yeux marrons
j'y demande pas ça je demande quel genre
de lunettes
noir la monture non les Verts
ah donc il veut des lunettes noires pour
des yeux marrons et il a qu'à essayer
ceci
vulgaire
nous en faisons beaucoup actuellement
oui c'est ce que je voulais dire
je l'énervais je sentais bien que je
l'ai énervé
il a qu'à essayer ceci alors
ah oui c'est mieux docteur c'est combien
celle-ci nous font 34 francs dit 33 non
sinon je fais pas ma marge
et celle-ci
celle-ci nous font dans les 250 francs
je m'en fous je suis riche
il sera pas déçu il y a plusieurs
écartements et c'est pas pareil c'est un
autre produit il sera pas déçu on en va
pratiquement jamais
mais tu es mon grand-père
je l'énervait vraiment
c'est à ce moment qu'il s'est venger en
me gâchant la vie
il a pas besoin d'autre chose
non merci
quel âge ça y fait là maintenant
ça vous regarde pas mon vieux
ça dépend il a dépassé les 45 ans
pas vraiment enfin si enfin qu'est-ce
que ça bouffe au foot oh rien c'est
juste pour dire tiens il a qu'à
s'asseoir là il a qu'à fermer l'oeil
droit il a qu'à lire le tableau qui est
là
si vous y tenez ah je voudrais tant que
tu te souviennes des jours heureux nous
étions amis en ce temps-là la vie était
plus belle et le soleil plus brûlant
qu'aujourd'hui non là il a triché il a
pas pu lire ça
il a qu'à essayer avec ses verres là
pour voir bon ben je recommence ah je
voudrais tant que tu te souviennes des
jours heureux nous étions amis en ce
temps-là la vie était plus belle et le
soleil plus brûlant qu'à Roubaix
il voit bien il voit bien qu'il voit
mieux
l'autre œil maintenant
et le soleil plus brûlant qu'à Roubaix
les feuilles les feuilles mortes ah non
il a qu'à essayer avec ses verres là
les feuilles d'impôts se rappellent à la
masse et ben oui et ben oui
il est presbyte
c'est grave docteur
ainsi donc j'étais handicapé physique
et je la prenais sans aucun ménagement
de la bouche de cette brute
ça m'a gâché la vie vous dis-je
car enfin Dieu m'enfourche à Longchamp
dans la 4e
qu'est-ce que l'avènement de la
presbytie chez l'homme sinon le premier
signe avant-coureur de l'inexorable
sénilité qui finira tôt ou tard par la
culée au tombeau sous les regards
soulagés de ses enfants chéris après la
presbytie voici que les cheveux de
l'homme se font de plus en plus
clairsemer ils se mettent à grisonner
autant cependant que ses muscles ça fait
c'est que ça fasse Molly
il se voûte il se plie il sera tatine 30
menu
puis il se met à chevroter ses pensées
se fixer et son dentier s'en va de la
vie il n'attend plus rien que son Télé 7
Jours
c'est le délabrement final
tout ça à cause de ce connard d'opticien
je lui jette ses 250 francs à la gueule
je le salue du bout de mes lèvres encore
gourmand mais pour combien de jours
encore
et je sors dignement abritant sous mes
nouveaux vers noir mon incognito de la
curiosité malsaine des femmes
disponibles que les beaux jours excitent
je tombe nez à nez avec deux bigottes
infâme la plus vieille dit à sa copine
vous avez vu cher ami c'est Jean-Pierre
déborde il a pris un sacré coup de vieux
[Musique]
quand tu as Sophie c'est pas pour cafter
mais il faut rien que megir dans nos
campagnes
[Musique]